la boîte on dit jeudi soir à 17,2 clame
à 10 h
l argument là ou non les beatles across
the nation ça fait depuis ces cinquante
ans que je travaille chez le permis
alors j'ai beaucoup d'expérience et
beaucoup de connaissances voudrais pas
que mes connaissances vont s'éteindre
avec moi je travaille surtout avec les
jeunes étudiant en agronomie
j'ai des fois aussi le tas comme ça je
leur donne des explications pour qu'ils
apprennent le métier j'ai la théorie
mais ça reste le pratiquer
je me suis roulé avec moi demandait
beaucoup de choses on pratique palmitate
et la culture viniculture s'estime
cultures fait très compliqués qu'ils
aient besoin de fonds ce lien que nous
crée entre les agriculteurs et les
associations de keita et nos étudiants
et enseignants est bénéfique pour nous
pour différents points donc le premier
point c'est d'avoir un feedback sur la
problématique agricole dans la région
le deuxième point c'est d'amener nos
étudiants sur le terrain pour vivre
réellement ces expériences troisième
point c'est pour pouvoir éventuellement
calibré et orienter notre formation sur
les réels besoins du secteur a dit qu'un
texte des halles pour des locaux lan
pays de par nos ordis associations à 39
des potentiels font pleurer maintenant à
d'autres indicateurs le secteur
le national a nommé l'un des supports
actions associées sur because we done
elvire policy maker quant à
l'association elle l'avait obligé
participer à leur assemblée générale et
j'ai vu que il ya un grand effort est
des choses qui font plaisir mais il
nécessite un accompagnement une écoute
beaucoup plus d'écouté de la part des
fonctionnaires du ministère mais aussi
localement la chambre l'administration
va travailler avec le représentant le
président de l'association mieux que de
travailler avec un ensemble
d'indicateurs il faut des états
organisations comme ceci associé legal
and exchanges with les autres de
partnership spork forme par les
organismes maintenant commenté jane
inculte comme vehicle for sustainable
development en corrigeant une langue
watts et nina de partir de cambrai
le government un set chose andrey
grechin procédure outre le rideau devant
les problèmes les implémentations de
granby locaux à développer la voiture
bonjour tout le monde
cela malgré tout je suis très ému de
revenir à alger après avoir quitté la
capitale il ya 40 ans de sa ans quand
j'ai terminé mes études ça l'émotion
était assez assez grande je suis venu
aujourd'hui pour discuter d'une
thématique et pour cela je voudrais
clarifier deux points d'abord ces deux
premièrement c'est que dans la
communication comme tout algérien qui se
respecte
la communication se fait à travers la
jonction de deux canaux un canal qui
vient du coeur un canal qui vient de
l'esprit donc
excusez moi si j'ai passé pragmatique
dôme à damas dans le développement de la
thématique deuxième chose que voudrais
clarifier
vous savez cette chemise c'est une
chemise emblématique c'est celle que je
porte chaque fois que je commence à
disserter sur des problèmes de culture
d'écologie
donc mon accoutrement quand vous voyez
rejoint un peu la thématique vous voyez
agriculture côté supérieur les
hydrocarbures côté inférieur
pour revenir à l'image que premièrement
ici plus de mille milliards de dollars
de rente de 2,2 rendre depuis 1962 à
titre comparatif la première recherche
un peu à la pire le plan marche au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
en 45 coûté 11 milliards $ en ce temps
là
actualisé à presque 300 milliards de
dollars actuellement pour reconstruire
une europe détruites
donc vous pouvez faire la comparaison
sans entrer dans les détails
l'essai baptisé ma première premier
slide entassent d'eric ça veut dire
excellent appareil de foire à skis à
travers lui on produit du pétrole de gaz
à droite et un palmier à gauche vous
avez dû à une production éphémère il
faut le dire
quatre gros gaz viendra le jour vont
disparaître à droite vous avez une
production père el hamdoulilah avec le
permis de lotir dans nos régions
c'est un premier set un arbre
emblématique je m'excuse je à mon âge
ici manipuler ces trucs là ça devient
difficile parce que les gars de ma
génération on le doit habituer à tour
les délivrer on est obligé de pousser
sur les parts alors que ce truc tactile
dérange un peu et nous énerve donc donc
seul et actuel l'inspiration c'est que
des experts des spécialistes disent que
en 2018 va être une année charnière
c'est à dire suivant la conjoncture
actuelle la situation que vit le pays
en 2018 la coupe de la consommation et
la courbe de la de l'exportation vont se
réunir et l'art sera la fin de la
récréation pour tout le monde n'est ce
pas vous savez tous que les prix du
pétrole dans notre pays du gaz en
plongez donc et vous savez tous que dans
notre pays la relève enfin on peut dire
ça des clips et les prix des
hydrocarbures frémissent pas mal de gens
commencent à trembler et ça c'est
dramatique c'est ce qu'on essaie de deux
d'expliquer dans ce dans une
présentation alors à titre comparatif
nous avons un chiffre que donner au
début c'est oui millions d'hectares
cultivables en algérie c'est à dire que
l'algérie vie potentielle de terres
qu'on peut cultiver
maintenant si elle avait vu millions
d'hectares à l'heure actuelle on ne
cultive qu'à peu près 60% des l'élite
des terres qu'ils peuvent produire c'est
à dire que si on arrivait à compléter
utiliser les terres dans leur ensemble
on pourra trouver une sortie de crise à
laquelle laquelle nous vivons qu'est ce
qu'on a ici on a alors la consommation
estimée à 2 5 % l'augmentation de 8 5%
par an le volume de production à 9% par
an alors que la crise des prix ces
derniers temps aussi en vous environs de
15 %
c'est à dire si on
on accumule tous ces chiffres là c'est à
dire que tous ces chiffres là mis
ensemble on va voir on va voir une
situation suivante
à ce rythme des dépenses les
importations les dépenses en général
même avec une augmentation entre 70 et
80 dollars le baril les spécialistes
prévoient qu'en 2020 il y aura un
endettement qui varie entre 40 et 50
milliards de dollars et qu'en 2025 1 aux
réserves de chansons puisées
c'est-à-dire ce scénario là c'est le
scénario qui est tracée par des gens qui
prévoient suivant le cours des
hydrocarbures
suivant la consommation suivant les
exportations quelle sera la situation
dans dix ans dans ce pays là sa truffe
c'est pas une vérité triste c'est une
vérité je veux dire à mr même dramatique
crise on peut faire passer on peut on
peut rectifier le tir mais c'est une
vérité qui dramatique dans la mesure où
nous sommes les seuls pays du maghreb à
ne pas avoir assuré sa sécurité
alimentaire depuis l'indépendance donc
la culture en algérie est une grosse
interne hâtives c'est par la seule
activité
c'est une grosse en terme hâtive que le
pays doit doit doit exploiter le plus
vite possible alors en algérie jusqu'à
les années 60 2 c'était le premier
exportateur de produits de la terre
alors ce niveau qui a été atteint par
part par le maroc en 2000 alors que nous
on a fait des années 60 ont été le
premier exportateur radicaux romands
démographie de 46 millions va être
atteinte en 2025
et la production agricole 30% cours des
deux dernières années
alors voyez les importations
alimentaires maintenant alors 1
milliards $ aux mines à 70,2 milliards
1980 2,7 milliards en 2003 8,9 milliards
en 2008 le garder le gap entre 2003 2008
et presque 7 millions 2,5 milliards de
dollars 2 remonte à sion
ce qui est vraiment très inquiétant
parce que au rythme où vont les choses
on va se retrouver vraiment notre
situation dramatique
alors pourquoi l'agriculture pourquoi
l'avertir le plus grand problème de
l'agriculture qui se posent en algérie
c'est le programme le problème du
foncier pas que les terres agricoles
n'ont pas trouvé ici une solution
policiers quant au niveau pour régler le
problème définitivement l'agriculture ne
prendra pas son essor comme il doit
l'être
la solution
bon on a parlé du sud algérien comme
solution aux problèmes agricoles
c'est vrai le territoire et grands les
conditions sahara sont réunis mais il
faut faire une approche qu'ils soient
scientifiques
on a fait des exploitations agricoles
immense au sahara puisse intervenir ce
n'est pas tellement rentable parce qu'au
sahara maintenant il faut préserver
l'environnement les ressources
hydrauliques et beaucoup d'autres choses
qui en principe ne sont pas prises en
charge en considération maintenant
l'ensemble des oasis et cent mille
hectares
vous savez que désert que sahara la
l'oasis et l'écosystème idéal depuis des
siècles qui a survécu à toutes les
attentes et à tous les changements
climatiques à toutes les conditions
quelle qu'elle soit et qui s'est jusqu'à
maintenant ça c'est le knock on suggère
aux gens lorsque l'on parle on discute
avec le haut responsable
l'écosystème oasien et l'écosystème qui
le plus approprié pour les ambitieux et
si on développe rsa sont mille hectares
c'est une sitution père-fils importante
et on peut même créer des oasis extra
muros dans les grandes villes qui ont
été bâties on peut créer des palmeraie
ailleurs et créer le même écosystème si
ce qu'on est en train de répéter à tous
moi alors les conseils là c'est tout un
paragraphe la main c'est tout à fait ça
je m'adresse à tous nos journaux
étudiants ici qu'ils doivent avoir une
vision de l'algérie de demain il ya une
chose qui est très importante et que je
recommande alors à nos jeunes aux jeunes
générations c'est de visiter les
territoires et les communautés
vous savez les élites algériennes
de par le passé n'ont peut-être pas
assumer leur rôle comme il faut mais il
n'est il est temps de revoir les choses
et de d'essayer de galvaniser cette
jeunesse pour essayer de de visiter le
territoire comme visiter leurs
communautés parce que le pays dans sa
diversité sa richesse il est
pratiquement vierge le pays immense il
est riche et quand il est immense riche
évident il peut attirer certains
convoitises et je voudrais que les gens
qui m'écoutent ici puissent analyser
tout ce que je dis il ya une chose aussi
qu'il faut faire en sorte c'est se
réapproprier l'histoire qui doit être
qui doit être allé avec le projet
société quand on parle des ingénieurs de
polytech ce n'est pas uniquement d'être
des ingénieurs pour investir le secteur
d'économies il faut aussi avoir un
projet de soucis en tête
ça c'est très important il ya le
problème de l'histoire que vous devrez
vous réapproprier l'histoire c'est le
socle pour bâtir ce pays là il ya aussi
un autre un autre détail qui qui qui est
très important c'est l'engagement dans
la dynamique de développement économique
qui doit vous menez inéluctablement vers
l'action politique parce que les deux
doivent être complémentaires
voilà brièvement les messages que
voulait se faire passer pendant cette
interruption j'espère que ce message a
été enregistré et je vous remercie pour
votre attention